[Musica]
questa sera sono felice di parlarvi di
una sfida molto importante la sfida
dello spazio e dell'economia che gira
attorno ad esso ci sono molte cose che
accadono che spesso non riusciamo
neanche a concepire immaginare
pensate che da vent'anni c'è sempre un
essere umano costantemente almeno un
essere umano in orbita questo grazie
alla stazione spaziale internazionale
fino ad oggi abbiamo avuto 558
astronauti nella storia il più giovane
di 25 anni il più anziano di 77 24 sono
andati oltre l'orbita terrestre e 12
sono arrivati fino anche alla luna la
persona che ha passato più tempo nello
spazio ci ha passato continuativamente
438 giorni dal 1957
abbiamo lanciato 9000 satelliti e molte
altre migliaia verranno lanciate nei
prossimi anni questa cosa riguarda anche
noi in modo diretto e una sfida che ci
tocca tutti è una sfida e per risolverla
dobbiamo cercare di connettere tanti
ambiti tante discipline e elementi del
sapere dall ingegnere aerospaziale alla
medicina dalle scienze manageriali alla
psicologia dall'astrofisica le scienze
planetarie
oggi parliamo anche di space economy
spesso l'immagine che abbiamo dello
spazio è legata a alla guerra fredda al
vecchio conflitto tra grandi potenze ma
stanno accadendo molte cose innanzitutto
c'è una riduzione drastica dei costi per
lanciare dei carichi in orbita questo è
un fattore abilitante per tante
applicazioni in secondo luogo c'è numero
sempre maggiore di paesi che può avere
accesso allo spazio e infine il settore
privato ha un peso specifico sempre
maggiore inoltre la cina agli stati
uniti le grandi potenze attuali hanno
anche una nuova corsa per motivi di
economia di difesa ma anche di orgoglio
nazionale e questo incrementa la domanda
i prodotti e servizi legati allo spazio
attualmente la spesa economy vale circa
130.000 430 miliardi di dollari ed è in
continua crescita da 10 anni in italia
parliamo di circa 2 miliardi di euro di
valore della produzione e circa 7 mila
addetti e nella filiera
tutto questo però non riguarda soltanto
ciò che verso punta verso le stelle ma
riguarda tutti noi anche in ambiti della
vita che possono sembrare sconnessi
dalla protezione dell'ambiente
all'internet delle cose dalle
distruzioni di stanza a molto altro
l'economia dello spazio ci tocca tutti e
alcuni soggetti pensiamo ai cosiddetti
baroni dello spazio come il mascalucia
branson jeff bezos che hanno fatto
fortuna in altri ambiti hanno intuito
prima degli altri che qualcosa stava
accadendo in questo in questo ambito e
quindi hanno investito ci sono poi
soprattutto migliaia di start up e di
pmi che stanno intervenendo su tutta la
filiera quelli con prodotti servizi
nuovi processi creando di fatto un
intero nuovo settore molte delle quali
tra l'altro posizionate anche in italia
questa storia inizia molto tempo fa si
parla di razzi
già nel xiii secolo la cina li usava per
scopi bellici venivano usati per questo
motivo in cina ma oggi ne abbiamo fatta
di strada
abbiamo dispositivi in orbita molto
diversi tra loro da robot sonde per
l'esplorazione cosmica telescopi
orbitanti stazioni spaziali come dicevo
prima abbiamo migliaia di satelliti 2000
sono anche operativi e abbiamo anche
della spazzatura spaziale dovuta alle
cose che non funzionano più
oggi abbiamo anche i satelliti che sono
sempre più piccoli si parla di naro
satelliti o cubesat quindi oggetti che
si riducono di dimensione costano poco e
possono essere talvolta anche realizzati
con elettronica di consumo o quella che
abbiamo negli smartphone i tunes at sono
oggetti molto piccoli con 10 cm di lato
pesano poco più di un chilo e anno
un basso costo e sono utilizzati per
sperimentazioni a basso costo
osservazione e così via
da vent'anni c'è la stazione spaziale
internazionale
secondo alcuni il progetto
ingegneristico più ambizioso mai
realizzato frutto della collaborazione
tra stati uniti e russia europa giappone
canada
abbiamo nuovi lanciatori e nuovi vettori
per gli esseri umani
da quando il programma shuttle si è
interrotto le aziende private sono
subentrate e hanno costruito nuovi
veicoli e soprattutto come vedete anche
in questa slide ci sono dei lanciatori
di nuova generazione cioè dei razzi che
possono portare oggetti e persone in
orbita capaci di rientrare in modo
controllato a terra
questa cosa importantissima immaginate
se ogni viaggio che fate in auto in auto
o in aereo o in treno
immaginate se in ogni occasione dovete
buttare via il mezzo sarebbe un costo
insostenibile bene
all'inverso avere dei lanciatori che
possono rientrare in modo controllato e
che poi riutilizzare fa da abilitatore
per tantissime applicazioni
siamo già abituati a molte delle
applicazioni della spesa economy dalle
telecomunicazioni alle previsioni
meterologiche tutti noi quando apriamo
uno smartphone
utilizziamo le mappe ci sono
applicazioni enormi nella navigazione
nella logistica dei trasporti ma anche
in altri ambiti come la sicurezza
militare o nella prevenzione del
cambiamento climatico
l'economia dello spazio inizia a
diventare anche un abilitatore
fondamentale dell'economia mondiale
un po come internet qualche decennio fa
sia in settori ad alta tecnologia ma
anche in settori a bassa sofisticazione
dove poi incrementare produttività e
creare posti di lavoro
pensiamo per esempio all'agricoltura
dove un monitoraggio migliore della
qualità del suolo dell'irrigazione della
biodiversità può produrre risultati
importanti
c'è inoltre l'economia digitale dove il
lancio di costellazioni di satelliti
cosa può fare può portare a creare
accesso a servizi internet a persone che
prima non potevano averlo quindi di
fatto
promuovendo anche quello che ho di fatto
un diritto umano a terra
noi già utilizziamo anche tantissime
tecnologie che derivano dalla ricerca
spaziale da alcuni sensori delle
fotocamere fino ad alcuni materiali
degli abiti che devono avere alta
resistenza ad alcune tecnologie mediche
fino alle tecnologie ambientali sempre
di più quello che accade a terra deriva
da quello che accade in orbita anche la
finanza ne viene toccata da molti punti
di vista
il volume di investimenti in venture
capital quella forma della finanza che
si occupa di investire le imprese ad
alto rischio e ad alta crescita sta
crescendo sempre di più nella spesa
economy nel 2019 sono stati investiti 4
miliardi di dollari cioè il doppio
rispetto all'anno precedente e anche qui
c'è un trend che dura da dieci anni
possiamo anche dire che ci sono delle
frontiere molto molto interessanti
pensiamo ad esempio al turismo spaziale
ci sono già stati finora sette astro
turisti o astronauti privati vale a dire
persone che hanno pagato per poter
volare e anche non troppo lontano da qui
c'è il futuro spazioporto a grottaglie
ci sono interi nuovi settori che possono
essere immaginati c'è chi parla di
estrazione mineraria dagli asteroidi e
dei corpi celesti
c'è chi parla di fare manifattura in
orbita c'è chi parla di utilizzare di
intelligenza artificiale e la robotica e
già lo farà tra l'altro per le sonde ei
satelliti e le stazioni spaziali
per non parlare poi delle nuove e
ambiziose missioni verso la luna e verso
marte tutto questo serve a che cosa
serve può aiutarci anche a me pare e al
re immaginare la società
noi possiamo lo spazio ci consente e ci
impone talvolta di collaborare per
collaborare per esempio tra settore
pubblico e settore privato di
collaborare tra nazioni di collaborare
tra discipline costruendo dei ponti e
delle sinergie
inoltre quello che accade nello spazio
non riguarda soltanto gli addetti ai
lavori
oa chi è iperspecializzato riguarda il
futuro e lo sviluppo di tutti noi
anche tu puoi contribuire anche tu se
vuoi puoi studiare e formati tramite i
molteplici corsi che sono online puoi
sperimentare puoi capire e diffondere
informazioni puoi partecipare ai
molteplici progetti collaborativi che
esistono sempre di più in rete ce ne
sono diversi dalla ricerca di esopianeti
fino al monitoraggio degli asteroidi
fino alla produzione di contenuti per
gli appassionati alla comunità del
settore c'è sempre di più la possibilità
di collaborare e contribuire dal basso
perciò l'aria speranza è che noi
possiamo e dobbiamo pensare al futuro e
di racconti dico caldamente che la
curiosità ci porterà lontano
grazie
[Applauso]